I know what welcome to the video playing
milk and won't cook and let's see ok ok
items o al queda recently I had a nice
win with us Zurich and at least it's a
line that I know from the from my book
g3 that's actually a pretty good line
that's not seen so often y term quite
often gets a slight advantage with this
g3 here with d 598 and Bishop g2 I think
yeah the capture the capture I'm not
afraid of let's see if or before is
probably not a good idea the 95 and I
can go and create them
Castle to e4 95 Bishop f5 yeah why not
it's at least somewhat active Kingu 94
though that the move I should have
thought about a little bit it's a more
normal actually and okay anyway it's not
so bad because that Bishop 1g2 doesn't
do much even simply capturing as
possible 95 is a bit more interesting I
don't know if that is a good idea though
he might take your form hmm ok I'm
playing this in a simple way
so are you okay I cannot move the night
because of g7 hmm yeah maybe he just
wants to take f6 play this play this
ending okay I'm pretty well centralized
so I don't dupe them fear that ending so
much ok c 5 mm not sure about this let's
do it
hmm set equal no I'm I worse would seem
that c4 porn is nice that I can detect
this pawn he forever is an issue yeah
this is this is a move that I was
thinking about and I wasn't sure what to
what to make of it really wasn't okay
i'm definitely going to take it this is
the most interesting move I think it
should be ok for black because i have
chances if i get to the six I'm just
better but I don't know if I ever do I
think okay yeah yeah III is that is
interesting try let's do it
not sure it's good but it's the only
really interesting okay wants to go FYI
yes go back keep this under keep this
attack that away okay now I get to this
sixth yeah this is a nice ending now for
black let's see and I have this
controlled and can push the pawns
five
f5 okay
should be seven I can just try to win it
you know this is the this is the the
most obvious way of doing it and prevent
that or put something on the dark
squares it's making sense anyway before
King c5 hoop dietas kind of thing or
just rookie 5 and take it take take take
everything before
you
should be a winking and porn ending at
the end things you should to take
everything takes King III before Jake
sticks King up it should win Oh is he
going g5 and I don't I don't don't
really believe it maybe g 5 i'm getting
into a self-penned yeah these are always
a little bit if he Angie fight I'm take
twice King takes his rents king of six
line and I cannot move jack
should you will take twice that I don't
believe it sigh yeah I came here he's
playing king and i can take this take a
tool and play play for the pawns
amazing stuff amazing that this all of a
sudden worked for wide Jack hmm i don't
know maybe i can still draw with the
pawn
threatening c3 maybe I'm still okay here
I go to check check
check for no time whatsoever I know you
can do here f8 god damn it and I don't
believe this lon sins and then you will
take there and win the king of porn
ending I don't believe it I'm losing the
game I still can't believe it Jack Jack
and I can draw time boys and I mean the
draw I absolutely should get here I mean
from a position that was completely
winning I guess gain what is better for
black I mean this ending is just a lot
better for like so I didn't didn't
manage what what the beep yeah we just
unbelievable that this doesn't work for
h 45 m the computer actually says
completely winning with before before
yeah maybe yeah maybe I can just push
that possible
huh well yeah yeah I'm just running the
sea porn yeah I mean okay that is bring
that is a win so it did not work I just
I just didn't didn't just stand here I
can go back for the drone okay yeah well
here I was so can actually entertaining
ideas to win the game with the pawns
this just seems to lose you to gauge aid
yeah it was ambitious move us as i
always play i mean i can i can just stay
and nothing happens but check yeah he's
willing check yeah so i have to have to
play before i didn't i didn't see that
didn't see at all okay a draw at the end
here on time again smoke thanks for
watching